Hey everyone. I'm going to share with
you all today. So, in this presentation,
uh this is just like a short workshop. I
know it's already been like a few days
since you guys started. So, it's just a
quick refresher on what we have. And
also, I'll give you a quick walk-through
on the builder hub. And we'll also be
having like a quick office hours so that
we can address any questions that you
have. Our team will also be joining
shortly, so we we could also help you
with the office hours.
And please do share any questions that
you have over there so we can address it
together. And this can benefit from the
same question as well.
So, before that, I'll just give you a
quick dive deep. I think you guys should
be much more familiar now starting off
with once you since you've started
building. So, it would have been a good
refresher of the topics that you might
have missed during your onboarding to
Zero G as well.
So, myself Gautam and developer at Zero
G. I just this just a quick presentation
on what Zero G is and what you can build
with Zero G and a quick rundown on our
infrastructure.
So.
The the biggest problem that we are
currently solving is the agent economy
where like the trust is the biggest
vulnerability. And there are like
damages, whether it may be like
exploits, whether it may be malicious
attacks, or like the trust that we are
currently putting in autonomous AI,
which is causing a big backlash because
the trust system doesn't work as
intended as the all the existing AI
solutions are completely centralized and
that acts as a black box. And you don't
get like a full context of what is
happening behind. What is the censorship
resistance mechanism?
Like how do you even trust the ex-
outputs that are given by these AI
models. So, there are like a lot of
things that are like hidden from the
users' endpoint. And it also is a single
point of failure when it comes to like a
centralized organization. So, in this
presentation, I'll just give you like
how Zero G is trying to solve this
problem using our stack, which is
dedicated for on-chain AI.
What is Zero G?
Just give me a second.
Yes. So, Zero G is the decentralized AI
operating system which acts as like a
foundation for the largest AI L1 chain.
So, this is like a layer one chain for
on-chain AI. So, we have a complete
stack from like an infinitely scalable
chain, which is EVM compatible. And we
have three core pillars on top, which is
like the storage, the DA, the compute.
And on top of that, we have the service
marketplace.
So, other than these, we have like few
other features like giving agentic ID.
So, where you can view your agent
identity, which I will dive deep into in
the upcoming section. And just moving on
with storage and DA.
So, the chain acts like a base layer
where all the transactions get settled.
It is completely fast. We have achieved
block time of like less than
one one second. And for the storage, DA,
and compute. So, the storage, you might
question like why do you need a storage
when there are other storage providers
in the market? Why do you need us like
to have your own storage into the
ecosystem? So, here the thing is that
the existing storage providers are
really expensive. And also, they they
are not meant to handle the throughput
of large-scale AI models uploading huge
datasets of GBs and TBs of data
onto like the uh
and giving them like an on-chain
verifiability. So, that is not what
other chains or like other storage
solution providers are intended to do.
But here, with Zero G, we have our
storage uh dedicated for you to upload
large-scale datasets, models, assets,
metadata, anything that you might need
to train and use that use those models
to get like verifiable inferencing. Next
comes like the DA layer. And with the DA
layer, it acts like an off-chain data
storage where you can just check for
like proofs. Later like once uh for
example, you're training some datasets
and the model is released. And like a
lot of people are using that models with
verifiable inferencing. If someone wants
to verify the history of like the
training data, they could use this
off-chain storage or like the data
availability layer to get access of like
the historical data.
Next is like the compute, which is like
the cream on top of the cookie that we
have.
So, with this, you will be able to get
verifiable inferencing from AI models.
All we have, we call it like a sealed
inference. So, the complete execution of
like the input-output stream that you do
a request for an AI model happens in a
TEE environment or a trusted execution
environment where like the input-output
system is not tampered by any external
agents.
And now, the training part will be live
soon. Currently, we have like the
verifiable inferencing live. And also,
we have the fine-tuning live. So, you
will be able to fine-tune the existing
models that are available on Zero G. And
if you want to like upload your own like
use your own model, then you would
require a H100 or H200 GPU. And using
this service marketplace, you will be
able to register your
AI model and use it as a provider and
get like the input-output usage or
Currently, we have like open-source
models like GLM 5.1. We just uh had it
live today. And other than that, we have
like 23.6. We have GLM 5. We have GPT
OS. Uh we have uh 30C. We have
uh 27B on the testnet. So, these are
like different models. And we have a few
other models as well, which you could
find on the docs uh to get like the
upgrade models list.
Moving forward,
uh just give me a second.
Yeah. These are the problems that are
you are facing the existing
uh the AI today. So, which I just gave a
quick brief before. So, it's like a
complete black box. You can't get the
data or the models.
And with vendor lock-in, apps depend on
closed APIs for pricing. So, you have
like no idea what was actually
inferencing cost and how much you are
being charged for the same thing.
But Zero G provides like open
decentralized storage and compute
markets that has no single vendor that
controls your complete infrastructure.
Next comes the ownership. So, users
don't own their agents or our open
system. It is owned by the centralized
organization. But here, with the
verifiable AI like attestations that you
receive, you'd have the ownership and
accountability that that model performed
as intended. And that also gives much
more confidence for like the DApp users
that you build using this AI
inference.
So, Zero G supports on-chain AI agents,
NFTs, which we have recently rebranded
to as agentic IDs. As I mentioned, I'll
just dive deep into the upcoming slide
on this topic.
And centralized control and censorship
is another big issue when it comes to
like centralized AI.
This comes into incentives. Yes, this is
the one thing like everyone are aware of
like what the platform charges and what
the builders
will be able to like get as an incentive
for like contributing to like whether it
may be like training these models or
whether it may be providing your own
GPUs for like the computation.
So, there's not a proper structure for
incentives.
With Zero G, as I mentioned, we have
like the four core components: the
chain, compute, storage, and DA. That's
it. I'll just keep just keep that in
mind. And let's pretty start with the
Zero G storage. So, just in this, so we
have like an inbuilt block layer
storage. The other storage that we have,
which we saw a lot of people having
questions in the hackathon, is the KV
storage. For KV storage, you can
actually need to run your own nodes. But
for other 51 for KV storage, you will be
able to achieve it with the existing
storage, the large storage that is
available. And for that, you don't need
to run any nodes. You could just start
with the SDKs and starter kits that we
have. And with the upload of function,
there's no requirement for flow
contracts that you previously used to
have. So, with these latest updates in
the SDKs, which I will solve clear a lot
of questions that you had in the office
hours.
So, with these latest version of SDKs,
it's all about using the upload of
function and download of function. And
this is how the process goes. So, when
you upload your data, so that data is
split into multiple chunks using a a
system called as erasure coding. And
that chunks of data are distributed into
the decentralized nodes. And once these
are uh like distributed, so that is one
part that is like the data storage. And
the other lane of data publishing
happens like simultaneously. So, that
what happens is when these nodes receive
these data chunks, it signs that signs
that it has received this data. And that
signed attestation is stored on the Zero
G contract. So, that is like that forms
up like a Merkle tree. So, the Merkle
rate gives you the complete system of
like how the data chunks are distributed
in between these nodes and you will
return back from zero G storage network.
All you All you All that is returned
back is like a root hash. So, with this
root hash you will be able to like
download the data uh back from the
network.
So, I currently we have uh recently
launched uh encryption and you'll be
able to get our encryption uh you you'll
be able to encrypt your data before
you're uploading it to zero G storage.
And this is a quick cost comparison that
you could see with AWS [clears throat]
S3 and with zero G storage and you could
see that you'll be able to achieve like
80 to 90% of cost saving even with
giving in the decentralization aspect
into it along with the verifiable
performance, tamper-proof, that is like
a decentralized redundancy. So,
for example, if node A is having chunk
A, there will be a there will be another
uh copy of that chunk in one other node.
So, there will be a redundancy in uh it
will avoid redundancy and you will also
have like a fallback mechanism. So, even
if a few nodes fail, there will be like
an alternative node from which that some
data chunk can be fetched.
So, uh all the like elaborate details
are available on the documentation. So,
please do check it out if you're
interested to learn much more technical
details before you start building.
Uh yes, this is GLM 5 that is live and
GLM 5.1 is live today. So, yeah, this is
like the 50 and the 30. You can you can
see KML proofs of like the that ZKML
proof that output that you received was
completely verified.
And uh next goes to like the zero G DA
and chain. So, this is the DA throughput
we have achieved of like 50 GBPS. Our
chain TPS is 11K and for the block
finality time we have given achieved
like a fine grain release uh second
block time which gives you the latency
similar to you utilizing like
centralized sources.
And this is one interesting thing that
you can utilize to build which is called
as agent ID.
So, with agent ID or like the standard
that our team has developed which like
the ERC-7857
uh is that you will be able to give like
a own like an identity to your AI
agents. So, I'll just give you a quick
down brief. So, why ERC-721
and 1155 falls short for AI? Because
it's static metadata, you can't like
that's incomplete transfer a transfer.
So, just the ownership moves, there's no
like connection between an agent and the
NFT and that doesn't mean that
when you're transferring an NFT, uh here
with agent ID or like this ERC-7857
if you transfer an NFT, it means that
you're transferring the ownership of the
agent to the other person.
Here with agent ID, you'll be able to
encrypt the model data and other details
of the model that is being used. So,
re-encryption on transfer. So, this is
what I mentioned. That's like a T oracle
that re-keys the metadata for the new
owner and there's like T and ZK proofs.
There's like 100 delegated users per
token. So, without transferring like the
NFTs, you can also like delegate like
access to different users who can
utilize that NFT without like completely
transferring the ownership to that
person.
So, yeah, these are like a few points of
like how agent ID solves this problem.
You could use this in your application
when you can use this as an identity to
your agents.
So, this gives like a quick details on
like how you can do this flow and uh
Yes, this is a quick brief on our
Aristotle mainnet uh as well. So, this
is live since September 2025. Aristotle
mainnet is uh like the main chain and
for like the testnet we have Galileo.
And we have 3.5 million dollars raised
from day one investors. We have 400
integration of our full stack and also
I'm proud to mention that we have the
largest ecosystem for on-chain AI
projects and uh please feel free to let
us know if you need any support from
other ecosystem projects and we can help
you get connected and we want you to
grow as an ecosystem and build for
on-chain AI, then you can get educated
with zero G, you can understand how we
can do it efficiently with zero G and
you can utilize all the ecosystem
partners' product and uh just start
building with and make AI trustless and
also decentralized.
And one other thing that I would like to
introduce is we have a ecosystem grant
program called build on zero G and we
have the 2.0 version that is currently
live.
So, what you can do is once you're done
building in this hackathon and you're
like looking forward to get personalized
assistance to scale the product for you
to like launch in the market, whether it
may be go to market support, whether it
may be like uh development support,
integration support, financial support,
we will be able to like provide the
necessary support for you post the
hackathon. So, please I'll share the
links once you're like once there's like
the details for the hackathon. So,
otherwise you could also check now it's
build.0gfoundation.ai.
So, that is a good place for for us to
like give like personalized support for
you to build on top of zero G.
And this is like the alignment nodes
that you might have seen when I showed
the architecture diagram. So, these are
like the nodes that we distributed over
a node sale to our community members.
So, this gives uh access all the power
to users to uh like have ownership or
like be part of the governance of zero
G's uh network in the future. So, yeah,
this uh
for like the development stage this has
no impact right now, but please do keep
in mind about like the alignment nodes
that we have and you could even like
have this to be part of the governance
of the zero G chain.
And uh yeah, just give a quick dive deep
on the price pool. Uh we have like two
tracks
it's halfway and you might have all
planned what you're planning to build.
So, by just giving a quick rundown,
first one is 7.5K dollars, second one is
also 7.5K dollars.
The first is for the framework and
tooling, the second is for like the
agents you build with the existing
frameworks and how you leverage zero G
with it. So, that is the core
difference, but both through gives you
like a complete generic space for you to
build
any idea that you have with any uh
domain expertise. So, you'll be able to
build that uh and And uh here are the
ideas that were shared with these
tracks. So, these are just like for uh
a small hint or like the idea bank for
you to get started, but by this time you
might have explored on few other ideas
as well and we got a few other
interesting ideas that uh
builders validated with us which seemed
pretty cool as well. So, we are really
looking forward to see you execute and
build this and get this idea live. So,
can't wait to see the projects out and
anytime if you need support with any MVP
that you've completed and you want us to
help get reviewed. Since it's an online
hackathon, please do DM us with the demo
link and we can review it as a team and
we can give you some feedbacks before
you go into the final demos.
And yes, I would like to conclude by
saying that uh this is the link to the
zero G's build.com and this is one
important thing most of you would have
joined by now, but if you haven't,
please do join the support TG channel.
So, here you can get necessary support,
whether it may be testnet tokens or
whether if you have you might have any
questions.
Uh also to know what any other small
office hours that we might connect in
future before the hackathon ends. So,
please do join this TG chat and if you
want to get in touch with me, it's and
at NT both on X and Telegram. So, please
do DM me with any queries that you have
as well. Uh so, thank you so much
everyone. Uh it was it was a pleasure
giving this presentation to you all and
I'm looking forward to jump to the
office hours section right now.